[Music]
my name is Dennis Roper and I'm the
product director for wear OS and I'm
really really excited to be here today
let me start with a little bit of
history by the way I need the clicker
you know when we first started we're oh
s four years ago we went out to see what
people were wearing and what we found
was a tremendous amount of diversity out
there people really care about what they
wear it evokes their passion their style
and their personality the same goes with
what you wear on your wrist is a really
really personal choice and so from the
start we made a decision to bring lots
of choice and diversity into the
wearable space today we couldn't be more
pleased how this strategy has played out
we have over 50 watches that are powered
by where OS today out in the market from
top brands like Louis Vuitton Michael
Kors fossil and many many others let me
show you some of the recent launches of
watches that we've that were introduced
in the market with our partners back in
the fall for the holiday season of 2017
misfit launched the mystic vapor
SmartWatch the misfit team did a great
job with this watch has a very sleek and
stylish design if it sprayed on your
wrist
and it makes for a great fitness watch
then this past January Kate Spade
launched the Kate Spade New York
SmartWatch it's a beautiful watch and
users are really loving that choose your
look app that matches your outfit with
your watch face and then this past March
at battleworld
who blow introduced a limited edition
SmartWatch called the Big Bang
referee 2018
this is a beautifully crafted SmartWatch
its body made out of titanium and with a
theme that celebrates the most popular
sport in the world soccer actually
really excited about this watch I'm a
big soccer fan myself and get this
referees are going to be wearing the big
bang referee at international matches to
help them connect with the latest goal
line technology that's really really
cool
so we're really excited about all these
new watches that are coming to market we
built a lot of momentum with our
partners to give you a sense of that in
2017 we launched 26 new watches that's
twice the number of watches that we
launched the previous year and an
interesting stat we're now seeing a lot
of iOS users in the wear OS platform
this past year in 2017 we grew a hundred
and forty eight percent year-over-year
in iOS users and today one out of three
new wear OS users activate their watches
with an iPhone and so this is why last
month we decided to change our name from
Android wear to wear OS by Google we
want a brand name that really reflects
the great diversity of users that we
have in our platform as well as the wide
range of choices of watches that are out
there we're really happy with this new
name our partners are really happy with
it and our users are loving it as well
so you know we've learned a thing or two
over the last few years working in the
wearable space and I want to share a key
insight with you guys it's a simple one
and perhaps an obvious one but the way
people use watches today is very very
different from how they use phones
they're very different in how people
interact with them how long they use it
how often they use it and what
use it for with a phone first of all you
carry it with you all the time and you
have two hands to interact with it has a
large screen and you can spend a long
time with it playing games doing social
media or responding to email with
watches is a very different story with
watches you use it you carry with you on
your wrist all day long but you use it
very sporadically and when you use it it
it's just for very short moments to get
some information and then the faster you
can be back doing what you're doing in
the real world the better so you know
we've taken these learnings to heart in
how we think about our platform going
forward and we're now focusing on three
very important areas to improve the user
experience let me walk you through them
first is connection at a glance second
is health and fitness and thirdly is
convenient and help from the Google
assistant let's start with connection at
a glance you know in this day and age
people are expected to be connected all
the time as I said before we carry our
cell phones most of the day but there
are some cases in which pulling out your
cell phone is inconvenient or sometimes
we just don't have it with us for
example when you go out on a run or on a
bike ride or if you go to a fancy dinner
dressed in an outfit with no pockets but
in any of these occasions you still want
to be connected to the people and the
information that you really care about
you know I myself I'm the father of five
kids and I also like mountain biking and
I can tell you from experience having to
put my cellphone in my backpack where I
carry water it's just really
inconvenient watches smartwatches fill
this gap really neatly you know they're
very easy to access there's a
of computing powering here and this is
one of the key reasons why users love
we're wearing where OS watches is to
help them have the peace of mind that
they can be freed from their phone but
still be connected to the information or
the people that they really care about
and so this is an area that's really
important connection at a glance and
we're doubling down on it to increase
the user experience and bring more to
our users to give you just a few
examples of things that we've introduced
recently in the areas of notifications
and complications let me show you real
quick here very recently we introduced
adaptive tech sizing which essentially
allows the glance ability of the
notifications should be much much better
because when you receive a short text
the size of the text gets bigger so it's
easier for you to read it we also
introduced recently darker backgrounds
and a new font type so we can increase
the readability and fit more information
onto the screen at a glance we've also
done things to improve our complications
no complications are these bite signs
bite-sized chunks of information that
they sit right on your watch face and
they're very handy little tools I myself
I use the agenda complication a lot he
really helps me many times during the
day to tell me where I need to go next
for my meetings so we've done more
because we think this is an important
area for people to stay connected very
recently we introduced the notification
preview complication this is a very
handy complication that brings the
top-ranked notification right on your
watch face things like breaking news a
chat message or your next appointment
will be right there on your watches with
this complication and we also introduced
another complication that we called the
recently launched app complication this
is one where is very handy when you have
types of information that you like to
axé is very frequently during the day
for example the weather or checking the
scores of a live game so this is just a
few examples of things that we're doing
to increase connections at the increased
experience for connections at a glance
and as I said before we're doubling down
in this area and you should expect a lot
more from us in the months to come next
is health you know health and fitness is
one of the most important reasons why
people buy a SmartWatch today people
want to be healthy of course and we at
wear OS are very committed to helping
people lead healthier lives so we're
doing more with it
we're helping we're working tirelessly
to give users the ability to track their
health much better than ever before and
also to offer them a more a superior
experience to track their active fitness
let me show you just a few examples of
things that we've done recently very
recently we launched a feature called
touch lock this is a great feature for
example if you go on a swim or you out
on a run on a rainy day and you're
tracking your workout with Google Sid or
any other application like my swim pro
Strava or RunKeeper with touch lock
enabled what happens is that your screen
basically gets disabled your touch
screen gets disabled to avoid any
unintended behaviors while your water
isn't but while your watch is in
constant contact with water to disable
touch lock all you have to do is click
on the button and you're back into
normal mode next is music you know music
is a huge deal for many people when
they're working out it helps them stay
motivated and energized and so we've
made accessing the music media controls
much much easier than ever before from
the Google fit workout
scream all you have to do is scroll down
from that screen and you get to the
media controls where you can choose the
next song that will help you power you
through the rest of your workout we're
also doing a lot more with a heart rate
sensor we recently introduced continuous
heart rate monitoring so you can check
your heart rate many times during the
day and you can also complete your
resting heart rate right from google fit
so this is just a few samples of things
that we're doing in health and fitness
where as I said before helping people
lead healthier lives is core to our
mission and we're working really hard in
many aspects of health and fitness and
we're going to be bringing a lot new
features in the coming months so stay
tuned
the last pillar that we're focused on is
the assistant convenient help from the
assistant you know today unlike
traditional watches that only give you
they're very good at giving you the time
with smart watches you expect to get the
best out of the time for example in my
case very very busy during the day I
could quickly look at my phone and be
able to check when the next train leaves
to San Francisco so can be home in time
for my daughter's soccer game we're
working really hard to improve the
experience for the assistant to optimize
for the wrist form-factor in a few short
minutes I'm going to invite Tom to come
on stage he's going to tell us a lot
more about what we're working on here
with the assistant so there you have it
these are the three areas that we're
focused on to improve the user
experience connections at a glance
health and fitness and convenient help
from the assistant but in order to do
this really well we require a very solid
and robust foundation here I'm talking
about things like power connectivity
performance the companion apps that go
along with the device and so on let me
just highlight three of them very
quickly first iOS as I said before we're
welcoming a lot of new iOS users and we
want those users to have a great user
experience just like anybody else that
is wearing a wear OS watch very recently
for example we introduced a brand new
iOS companion app that brings google fit
summary stats right on the app so you
can see it from the comfort of your
iPhone this is just one example of many
things that we're doing to improve the
iOS experience next is power power is
really really important when it comes to
smartwatches
and we're working across the we're aware
stack to optimize battery consumption
right after Tom we're going to invite my
colleague Rotti she's gonna tell us a
lot more about what we're doing with
Android pee and how this has a positive
impact in power and lastly I'd like to
highlight that we're bringing faster and
more frequent updates to the platform
that's really really important for users
that they get continuous improvements to
the watch constantly throughout the year
with where 2.0 we make changes to our
architecture so that pieces that were
considered to be traditionally part of
the OS are now updatable platform
components and as a result of that this
past year in 2017
we're able to do 11 releases to the
platform and introduced 49 new features
and improvements this year we're on
track to do the same or even higher we
have a where we're introducing a lot of
features really really fast and we're
really excited about that so as I said
before the Google assistant is one of
the key pillars that we're working on
really really important for us and I'm
going to invite Tom onstage to tell us a
lot more about it
thank you thanks Dennis hi I'm Tom and I
work on the assistant for where OS we
won't be assistant to follow you across
all of your devices and when you
interact with the assistant it should
adapt to the device that you're using
and for where we want to provide an
awesome assistant experience right on
your wrist with our last update this
week we've completely redesigned our UI
and have three major improvements that
I'd like to talk to you about first we
have an always present microphone which
automatically reopens to continue the
conversation with the assistant
hands-free second support for
text-to-speech if you have a paired
Bluetooth headset or a wearable device
that has a speaker when you talk to the
assistant now can speak right back to
you and lastly my favorite support for
suggestion chips suggestion chips allow
you to breeze right through a
conversation just by tapping but the
biggest new addition for wear is support
for actions on Google actions on Google
allow anyone to write a great wearable
experience without having to write a
single line of Android code even better
most existing actions already work on
where OS today without any changes so
let's take a look at how this works you
may have already used dialogue flow to
build actions for the assistant it's a
platform provided by Google that helps
to turn natural language into a format
that you can just go and build cool
stuff with and starting this week you
can also use dialogue flow to create
actions for where OS best of all we've
already done all the hard work of
building out response templates that are
appropriate for wearable devices so you
don't even have to think about it if you
haven't used dialogue flow yet it's
super easy just yesterday I was creating
my own action I only had to define this
action once and will work across all
supported devices here's what it looks
like on mobile this might look pretty
familiar
there's an action icon at the top at a
pible list of the Google i/o sessions I
plan to go to and a suggestion ship at
the bottom and this is how it looks on
we're all the same components exists but
now they're tailored for a smaller
wearable form factor I didn't have to do
anything special for this to happen it
just works and now even if you're going
a little bit deeper and you're using the
actions SDK or a web hook for
fulfillment we still have you covered in
this case I'm adding a new card to the
conversation that has a little more
information about this session and this
is how the card will render on both
phone and where it automatically resizes
and looks great regardless of which
device is being used so over the past
few months we've been building and
testing a lot of actions and we've come
up with some best practices to help your
actions look really great on ware let's
start with an example
okay Google asked patrons when is the
next Bart from Fremont to Hayward
there's supposed to be an animation of
Bart from Fremont to Hayward leaving
today at 11:21 a.m. cool
so as Dennis mentioned earlier we want
users to have glanceable interactions we
want users to get tasks done quickly we
want to allow users to complete a task
with a single phrase in the previous
example I was able to get the
information that I asked for by speaking
a single phrase imagine if I had to
specify all that information separately
the Train that I wanted the station the
direction of travel that would take way
too long and I'd be far more likely to
just pull out my phone
keep your dialogues too short concise
and task oriented now there are cases
where having a back and forth dialogue
is important and maybe even required and
that is fully supported on where today
however try not to make it part of your
core user journey as you may have just
heard
we're now supports vocal responses and
they don't have to be the same as a
visual in the previous example both the
visual response and the vocal response
tell me when the next train lives that's
what I asked for but the visual response
goes a step further and shows a more
detailed list of departures that
information would probably be a little
bit too dense to read aloud vocally but
visually it works really well
independently both the vocal and visual
response makes sense but together they
really complement each other and make an
awesome experience keep in mind that not
all devices supports or support vocal
feedback so you can use surface
capabilities to really tailor your
experience to the device that's being
used so vocal responses are cool but my
favorite new feature is suggestion chips
so I have to admit I'm a little nervous
last few times I came to Mountain View
it rained and I forgot my umbrella got
soaking wet I know it looks like a nice
day out there today but let's ask the
assistant to see how things look
okay Google do I need an umbrella today
right cool not expected to rain this
weekend I was planning on going for a
hike and I can use suggestion chips to
get that information quickly the weather
for this weekend I can just drag up on
the bottom drawer where the microphone
is located which will reveal suggestion
chips and I can tap on weather this
weekend to quickly get the forecast for
the weekend the weather looks great I
should bring my sunscreen
I love suggestion chips not only are
they a great way for guiding users
through a conversation they also allow
users to discover what your agent can
and cannot do provide example chips
whenever possible to guide users through
a conversation when thinking about how
to build your action be user centric
they might be someone might be using
your action in a lot of different ways
they might be on the go their hands
might be full and vocal responses might
be more appropriate or they could be
somewhere noisy and suggestion chips are
the easiest way for them to tap through
an interaction design with all these use
cases in mind we've had a lot of fun
building support for actions on Google
and you can get started building your
own agents today I am so excited to see
what you're going to build and if you
need some inspiration we have a lot of
great partner demos in our sandbox and
you can come by after the session to say
hi and check them out and if you're
interested in building actions I
definitely recommend to check out the
design actions for the Google assistant
session which starts right after this
one on stage two but don't go just yet
because up next is Rotti to tell you
about our platform updates thanks Tom hi
I'm Rafi I'm a technical program manager
working on where OS don't just showed
you how to build really cool assistant
actions and Google's for where users now
let's move on to the platform updates
that we have with the new where OS
release we are introducing platform
features that would help you to offer
delightfully stable and battery
efficient experiences throughout your
apps and help you build really cool
watch faces with just a few lines of
code to begin I'd like to talk about an
Android a feature that is going to
impact you as a developer Android B is
adding restrictions on accessing methods
and fields unsupported by the SDK to
improve app compatibility and to prevent
apps from breaking where OS is adopting
these restrictions with a goal of making
a behavior deterministic and stable this
is very similar to what the developers
on my team face just before a product
launch the deadlines and restrictions
can make people
a little unhappy as a dashing to meet
the deadlines but come launch date the
team is really happy when they're able
to launch a stable and reliable product
that meets our users needs to check out
the app compatibility link
jiko slash dev slash app compat to
understand what these changes mean for
your apps
moving on to battery battery is precious
on mobile and even more so on where last
year at i/o we highlighted that most
watchers have just 1/10 the battery
capacity of a phone and we shared some
best practices on improving battery life
we also indicated that we would be
looking for ways to be more aggressive
than the phone in addressing battery
usage this year we're moving beyond the
mobile platform and introducing features
to reduce background activity
aggressively turn off radios when the
user takes off the watch and enhanced
battery saver mode let me walk you
through some of them here's a snapshot
of the app standby feature that was
introduced in yesterday's talk what's
new in Android Beam on where OS we are
experimenting with a more aggressive
platform change apps that are not active
will not be able to create jobs or
alarms when they are not on the charger
now even when they are in the active
bucket they can only start jobs or
alarms if they are in the foreground
what do you mean by foreground well an
active app running in the foreground is
an example a watch face currently active
on your dial complications on your
currently active watch face and in very
rare circumstances say if your health
monitoring app a foreground service
running on the watch all of these can
create jobs and alarms
if you are aware abdullah / be sure to
experiment with these changes in the
developer preview and provide us with
feedback another platform feature that
is being revamped in the upcoming
release is battery saver mode we are
enhancing this mode to go beyond the
phone platform to aggressively squeeze
that last ounce of battery and prevent
the watch from turning off on users
wrists during the day in this enhanced
version of battery saver mode we would
be turning off all radios touch until
detection and would be defaulting to a
battery optimized watch face users get
short breaths to read the time and long
press to resume full operation and this
could be particularly helpful if your
watch is running low on battery but you
want to quickly be able to turn it back
on to say make a payment or to check an
important message continuing with our
efforts on improving battery life
last month we moved to using a dark
theme for our system apps as Dennis
mentioned earlier now this teaming has
the dual benefit of improving glance
ability and accessibility while reducing
power consumption in P we're bringing
these changes to the platform and
updating the default system UI to use
the dark theme to try these changes out
on your app using the current developer
preview I'd like to leave you with some
best practices for watchface design as
you know what faces are the most active
apps and frequently are doing too much
too often as developers you have the
ability to influence how long users can
experience and enjoy your watch faces
using simple coding techniques to save
battery let me share a few best
practices with you display CPU and
twork are the most battery intensive
components of the system be mindful of
the frequency at which you are reading
processing or displaying information on
a watch face for example if you're
reading a sensor and doing calculations
every minute or sending an RPC to the
companion every minute this can
significantly impact the battery life
and once you have the new data from the
sensor or the network you would also
have to wake up the system to process it
process of wake ups are more expensive
for battery life than the power consumed
by individual sensors like the
accelerometer so that's your sensor
requests and network calls batching can
go a long way in conserving battery life
finally moving on to some developer
tools last year Android and as a result
we're OS officially started supporting
Kotlin now you can already take
advantage of a lot of language features
like compile time null checks and lambda
support but to get the best out of
Kotlin we need to go beyond what the
language offers by default on where we
are experimenting with creating a domain
specific language or DSL for watch faces
so you can get rid of a lot of the
boilerplate code the initial results are
quite exciting we reduce the watch face
creation code of 600 class lines to just
under 15 lines of code and here's a
snippet of what the DSL looks like this
simplified interface allows you to focus
on the design and customize your watch
faces using just a couple of lines of
code while incorporating best practices
to boost the performance and battery
life of your designs we're very excited
about the opportunities that Cottenham
provides and are just beginning to
scratch the surface on simplifying
development on where OS we look forward
to your feedback
while we work towards adding this to our
official SDK check out the code labs at
i/o and visit the where OS sandbox to
share your feedback and ideas to
summarize you've officially supported
methods and api's instead of private
api's to improve compatibility and
stability of your apps design your apps
and watch faces to be battery efficient
remember batching is your friend
download the PDF lopper preview and
check out how your apps are impacted by
the battery saving features that we are
introducing and finally give cotton DSL
a spin using the code lab and let us
know what you think with that let me
hand it back to Dennis for closing Thank
You Rotti all right to recap we're
working really hard to improve the wear
OS experience in three key areas
connections at a glance health and
fitness and that Google is an ague bolas
is an experience that is optimized for
the wrist we're also improving the
platform with new battery saving
features and new tools for developers
and also you can expect a lot more and
frequent updates from us during the year
today's session is just a beginning for
us here at i/o at 2:30 p.m. we have
office hours where you can meet with our
engineers and our developer relations
Oaks come on by if you have any
questions they'll be really happy to
receive you and talk to you about
anything that you'd like to do to talk
about regards to where OS and at 11:30
a.m. tomorrow we have an app review
session where you can bring your where
up your complications or watch faces to
get feedback from our engineers and we
also have a sandbox here's a map of
where it is please come visit us Tom
ratty and I will be there right after
this session as well as many of
colleagues at where OS we also have some
cool demos there to show you and a full
lineup of some of the most recent where
OS watches that's all thank you very
much for coming and have a great IO
[Music]